councillor Ken Clark who joins us now
from Westminster good evening mr. Clark
evening what was the big story few this
budget oh I was reassured by this it was
strong steady hand stuff he did not give
in to all the pressures to start paying
out money to all these various lobbies
on a Corbin like basis I thought the
things he concentrates are particularly
going for the housing market where the
right priorities I didn't lose it all
but mainly I was extremely glad that it
was it was trying to be a responsible
budget it was taking account of what I
think unlike Roger brutal will be there
rather uncertain the perhaps weakened
state of the economy for the next two or
three years so I was quite reassured
that he hasn't given me into all the
short-term political buffeting that he'd
been subjected to like every other
Chancellor always is before a budget
what about the capital investment I mean
the Chancellor does seem to try to
target a bit of money towards that do
you think that's gonna work well I think
infrastructure investment is perfectly
okay he cited the very big projects we
already have underway particularly like
cross rail and hs2 and hs3 that's fine
no they're in themselves they don't cure
the economic problems that we have but
they're a good basis for the future I
like what he said about technology I
hope someone's going to follow up and
what he said about skills training and
helping people get themselves up to
speed for the modern economy there are
the things that matter and that's the
judgment you should apply to a budget
all these forecasts are always uncertain
economic forecasters it's going to use
the best you can get
next week's headlines will be a load of
old rubbish and we've forgotten by next
Christmas what matters if in a couple of
years time it does look as though your
budget decisions have helped recovery
growth some stability jobs and so on and
this was Chancellor aiming at that I
think I think that was his long-term
vision which Rodger was just talking
about and there's been a misses in terms
of fiscal easing this is probably the
biggest that we've seen since the
financial crisis would you have done
this I'm surprised it turns out it was
so big I was rather relieved that he
hadn't gone in for too much fiscal year
easy and he's got a bit of leeway
but not very much I think I just about
forgive him for getting this far he
didn't want to things that I wouldn't
have bothered to do myself and although
politically he's an impossible situation
we have no majority and some
backbenchers six emails on there
anybodys you know I would have tried to
tighten up perhaps a little bit more
than him so obviously despite his
reputation he's no more a fiscal Hawk
than I am and he hasn't it isn't this
isn't mad fiscal loosening and as has
just been said the outlook for the stock
of debt and the outlook for the deficit
more encouraging for a long time if the
ABR's anywhere near right they will
start coming back to more sensible
levels indeed the annual deficits almost
there now let's take a trip down memory
lane mr. clock picture of you presenting
your last budget enjoying a whiskey at
the dispatch box what would you advise
Philip Hammond to have drunk today oh
well I was followed by a Scotsman who
didn't wanted to stretch that didn't
want to smoke drink whiskey I mean it
was quite extraordinary everybody but
gladsome had drunk something I've no
idea what tipple I've chosen today but
something he probably had to be a rather
more sober day he claimed he had
something in a carafe but he he didn't
in the end turn to use it so given the
outlook he faced before he came to draw
this and given all the attacks the
Euroskeptics were launching on him I
personally probably would have read you
to DRAM before faced an ass but there we
are all right Kent Clark good to see you
thanks for joining us